if we can get him to drive to get out of  here and we're going to rock slide in  his hair what the hell is this what are  you trying to cup a feel or something no  dude no dude no dude i was just  listening  god i don't even i don't even know how  to explain this um  uh dwight asked me to be in an uh  alliance  and then um  um  we were we've just been messing with him  uh because of the whole alliance thing  um it's just office pranks it's stupid  it's just office pranks and alliance  what the hell's he talking about  i have absolutely no idea  come on  do i feel bad about betraying jim  not at  all  that's the game  convince him we're in an alliance get  some information throw him to the wolves  that's politics baby